nouvel épisode de la série dans son
corps aujourd'hui je reçois gens de la
chaîne acropolis qui vient nous parler
de sa particularité à lui qui n'est pas
si particulière dans la mesure où elle
est très répandue et justement c'est
bien l'intérêt d'en parler
[Applaudissements]
genre et streller et youtube heures il
tient la chaîne acropolis qui parle de
politique et des institutions publiques
en france salue jean c'est julien alors
quelle est ta particularité à toi la
particularité à moi c'est je suis
atteint d'une maladie qui s'appelle la
dépression la dépression est une maladie
fréquente puisqu'on estime qu'en france
elle touche une personne sur cinq au
cours de sa vie à l'échelle mondiale
elle touche 300 millions de personnes je
peux raconter un peu ton histoire par
rapport à ça ouais avant le moment où tu
t'es rendu compte que j'avais un truc
alors c'est vrai c'est génial parce que
précisément dire de la dépression que
c'est une maladie c'est déjà en soi une
gageur et c'est un sujet intéressant
parce que c'est une des preuves que la
dépression est mal comprise y compris
par les personnes qui en sont atteintes
et donc justement pour répondre à ta
question à quel moment est-ce que je et
ben en fait de ses parents je ne sais
pas parce que la dépression c'est pas
une maladie qui se déclenche c'est pas
vraiment comme ça que ça marche c'est
plutôt un truc qui s'installe en temps
et donc qui ce diagnostic longtemps
après et à l'avenir de la culture
comprend des choses plus tard donc moi
ça fait plusieurs années que je souffre
d'un truc sur lequel un diagnostic a été
posé assez tôt mais qui est un
agnostique que j'ai refusé pendant
longtemps et refuser un diagnostic ça
veut dire que que que j'étais dans le
déni que je veux que je pensais que
c'était juste débattre des problèmes de
d'humeur psychique des trucs passagers
en fait des 13 personnalités des trucs
comme ça et il a fallu il a fallu des
années de
de travailler beaucoup de médecins pour
que je finisse par accepter l'idée que
j'étais atteint d'une maladie et que ça
s'appelle la dépression et que c'est
particulier la dépression c'est une
maladie elle a des origines diverses et
elle peut se manifester de différentes
façons pour toi est-ce que tu souviens
tu parles espèce de acceptation à une
prise de conscience tu te souviens d'un
déclic un moment ou un autre
chaque personne atteinte de dépression à
une manière différente de la vivre c'est
aussi très compliqué du coût de la
détecter de la comprendre etc
mais c'est comme ça et moi en
l'occurrence aller très cyclique et elle
fonctionne par avec des hauts des bas et
quand il ya des quand il ya débat ça
ressemble beaucoup à des burn out par
exemple c'est un autre mot qu'on entend
beaucoup et moi il ya un burn-out très
violent que j'aie fait qui m'a emmené à
l'hôpital
où j'ai où j'ai pris conscience où j'ai
pris conscience effectivement où il ya
eu un déclic un autre déclic a été
important à ce moment là au même moment
et c'était d'ailleurs dans la même
semaine c'est un livre que j'ai lu
qu'ils s'appellent rester en vie c'est
un point qui m'a beaucoup aidé parce que
ça parle de la dépression et notamment
de la prévention du suicide et c'est un
livre qui m'a appris que j'avais le
droit d'être et des bas c'est con à dire
mais j'avais besoin de me l'entendre
dire à un moment pour comprendre que ok
en fait ça va apparemment fait c'est
vraiment une maladie
en fait ils ont raison de me dire que je
suis malade est en fait allé on allait
il faut y aller quoi donc voilà c'est
cci à vis des cliques là parce que
refuser d'accepter qu'on est malade
c'est aussi du coup se priver de la
possibilité de se révéler et absolument
et c'est un vrai problème surtout pour
cette maladie là qui est qui a qui a
besoin d'être soigné qui se soigne
d'ailleurs et ça aussi c'est important
mais l'acceptation de la maladie est une
étape difficile par laquelle il faut
passer pour commencer à trouver le
chemin de la sortie quoi donc avec deux
ans de recul maintenant est-ce que tu
arrive un peu à comprendre ce qui te
bloqués dont on pas ce qui l'empêché
d'accepter le fait que tu avais cette
maladie à savoir la dépression c'était
quoi c'était c'était la culpabilité
c'est une maladie très stigmatisante la
dépression déjà parce que le regard
extérieur comporte dessus et empreint de
clichés en fait on confond très souvent
la dépression avec un état avec un état
d'humeur la dépression est une maladie
qui touche l'humeur la dépression c'est
pas la déprime ans c'est pas le spleen
c'est pas la mélancolie c'est pas la
tristesse c'est plus que ça ça en fait
partie sont des symptômes mais c'est
plus que ça c'est aussi un
affaiblissement global de thé défenses
immunitaires et de ton métabolisme
c'est un ralentissement de son rythme de
vie du fonctionnement de son cerveau
c'est des troubles du sommeil c'est des
troubles de l'érection c'est des
troubles digestifs
c'est beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
choses la dépression est donc cette
stigmatisation de la dépression je la
ressentais pour moi même
[Musique]
et donc du coup elle me et du coup elle
me faisait douter du coup je
culpabilisais parce que parce que parce
que après tout bas je suis pas sportif
donc c'est peut-être un peu aussi de ma
faute parce qu'après tout jeu clope
j'ai une hygiène de vie assez
dégueulasse enfin je veux dire à ces
communes nous promet-on d'opération mais
c'est comme ça et puis en plus j'ai un
chai j'ai fait des choix de vie très
spécifique j'ai bossé dans la politique
j'ai bossé aujourd'hui sur youtube c'est
quand même des milieux dans lesquels bah
c'est pas anodin quoi je veux dire ils
ont vidé truc assez intense et donc donc
donc je me sentais en fait responsable
ou un minimum complice de ma situation
donc c'est pour ça que je n'acceptais
pas le diagnostic et le le regard des
autres
à quel moment et dans quelle mesure est
ce qu il a joué en ce qui concerne il a
beaucoup joué parce que la dépression
est pas une maladie pour laquelle les
symptômes sont visibles
une personne qui souffre de dépression
c'est une personne qui rit c'est une
personne qui va au cinoche
c'est une personne qui est boit des
coups qui est sympa qui est sociable qui
continuent à vivre normalement et donc
du coup ça se voit pas c'est pas comme
s'ils avaient des plaques sur visage ou
des trucs comme ça et donc du coup il y
avait le regard des gens dont j'ai
beaucoup souffert qui était celui de la
surprise quand j'ai enfin accepter la
maladie j'ai commencé à en parler de
gens qui ont qui eux l'ont gagnée comme
moi je la mets avant et donc ils m'ont
envoyé une image de savane on met pas du
tout si oracle doit d précisément le
poids du tout oui ça va on aussi on a
des petits passages où on est on est
vidé tout est en fait on est pas mal
souffert de ça du fait de pas être
compris que non mais je te parle pas du
fait que j'ai mal dormi hier sans je te
parle d'une maladie que j'ai eu
plusieurs années qui me pèse beaucoup et
est maintenant ça va mieux
un peu mieux parce que j'ai appris en
parler aussi différemment j'ai appris à
poser les mots j'ai appris à l'affirmer
et c est par ailleurs j'ai aussi eu des
regards extrêmement bienveillant des
gens qui m'ont tendu la main des gens
qui m'ont accompagné qui m'ont aidé et
qui m'ont fait beaucoup de bien juste en
me disant je suis là si tu as besoin
ça c'est une phrase génial par exemple
j'ai jamais rappeler quelqu'un qui m'a
dit si tu as besoin appelle moi mais le
simple fait qu'il m'ait dit cette phrase
m'a toujours fait beaucoup de bien c'est
con mais tu vois là ça aussi c'est un
regard des autres qui qui est vachement
pour l inverse tout ça peut être quelque
chose quitte enfonce comme ça peut être
quelque chose qui te wei te saura
exactement exactement plein est par
rapport à ton propre regard sur toi-même
il ya eu quelque chose de l'ordre de
l'estiment 2
de toi complètement accepté le
diagnostic de dépression s'est déprécié
sans vie d'un jeune homme j'ai beaucoup
de nous oui et en même temps dans
l'autre sens c'est vrai aussi c'est à
dire que oui c'est pas facile de se
regarder dans la glace et se dire je
suis atteint de dépression
il ya un côté zerrad misérabiliste et en
même temps à l'inversé aussi de se dire
ok j'ai le courage de me regarder en
face dans la seine loisirs ouais mec qui
était atteint de dépression et ça m'a un
peu ouais un peu et d aider a affirmé à
savoir ce que qui j'étais à arrêter de
douter à savoir quand j'étais dans des
nues quand je n'étais pas pareil quand
j'écoutais les autres de savoir qu'il
était dans le déni et qu'il n'était pas
et donc d'emplois et vis-à-vis de
vis-à-vis du rire qu'on a sur soi même
c'est particulier d'autant qu encore une
fois la dépression est une maladie qui
est un qui impacte l'humeur et l'estimé
de soi et donc c'est très très
particulier comme maladie au quotidien
cela pourrait dont deux assez concret et
étalée sur le temps du début a
aujourd'hui fait ste man tu es tu gères
un peu mieux les les choses les plus
difficiles à vivre pour toi c'est quoi
ces les
c'est les crises d'angoissé l'inde est
l'un des aspects de la dépression c'est
l'anxiété qui en est un moteur est un
symptôme très bizarre mais c'est comme
ça
que je vis très mal
il ya aussi sûrs
les médicaments que pendant longtemps
dans le cadre du déni je refusais
prendre je les prenais mal je lis
refusait il y avait un truc très très
violent et dans l'estimé de soi aussi
prendre des médicaments ne faisait me
faisait mal quoi
donc ça a été ça a été ça le plus
difficile après c'est des troubles du
sommeil
je dors énormément et je dors très mal
donc c'est des insomnies cd sieste au
milieu de la journée à ce que parce
qu'il n'y a pas le choix parce que juste
je m'effondre de fatigue
et puis sur l'estimé de soi on en parle
tout à l'heure le fait de pas être au
niveau professionnellement aussi ça ça
c'est difficile à vivre parce que la
dépression que je le disais tout à
l'heure ralentis et puis c'est une cc
c'est la dépression te fait perdre ce
qu'on appelle le souffle vital et donc
l'envié de faire les choses et c'est une
maladie qui touche l'apathie donc la
capacité qu'on a à ressentir du plaisir
à faire ce qu'on fait ça dans le milieu
pro mon gars c'est ça a été très
compliqué à vivre mais heureusement je
vais t'accompagner j'ai des idées mais
justement al'inverse les avec le recul
maintenant puisque tu t'es sur le chemin
de wayne j'espère jeu vers la guérison
mais tu sais de la même manière qu'on ne
peut pas dire à quel moment ça a
commencé une dépression on ça s'arrête
pas un jour il ya un jour où je serais
très très content d'affirmer avec le
sourire que j'étais malade avant ce jour
là viendra mais pour l'instant mais je
sais pas quand c'est pas forcément un
objectif qu'il faut se fixer vos ce
qu'il peut paraître inatteignable
l'objectif c'est peut-être juste de se
dire je
je suis dépressif j'ai une dépression
mon objectif en tout cas comme le
premier pas c'est de continuer à vivre
avec ça d'apprendre à vivre avec ça en
progressant jusqu'au jour où je pourrai
me dire c'est derrière moi exactement
exactement et c'est ça aussi qui est
intéressant dans cette maladie c'est
toute la notion justement de maladie de
guérison de pathologie et c'est parce
que j'ai aussi beaucoup appris sur la
dépression en renseignant et en
m'informant dessus et j'ai appris que
c'est une maladie qui fait l'objet d'une
controverse médical très intéressante
entre des chercheurs qui ont des
approches différentes des choses il ya
une approche psychanalytique de la
dépression mais il ya aussi de nouvelles
approches notamment du côté des
neurosciences tout ça est très technique
tout ça est très compliqué mais tout ça
montre bien qu'en fait la dépression est
une maladie mal connue mal comprise y
compris aujourd'hui par le corps
scientifique qui fait des progrès et des
beaux progrès il ya des belles choses
qui sont faites il ya des progrès sur
des molécules anti dépresseurs qui est
qui qui qui ont été faites
donc donc oui effectivement guérir d'une
dépression c'est se passer de
médicaments c'est apprendre à vivre avec
apprendre à maîtriser ses angoisses et a
donc c'est un long travail à mon avis
est multifactorielle n'y a pas de magie
que ça faut vraiment aussi se mettre ça
dans mon crâne mais c'est beaucoup
beaucoup de choses à faire
toi concrètement les trucs qui t'on
vraiment aider à avancer à vivre avec
une premier temps c'est que c'est quoi
alors il ya eu
il ya eu il ya eu plusieurs choses
d'ailleurs il ya eu des vidéos sur
youtube
je pense notamment une vidéo du psy lab
où ils ont parlé de la dépression sur
laquelle j'ai grâce à laquelle j'ai
appris j'ai appris beaucoup de choses
qui m'a aidé à comprendre cette maladie
il ya le livre dont j'ai parlé tout à
l'heure
il ya aussi des médecins qui m'ont
accompagné et des médecins de l'hôpital
aujourd'hui je suis suivi par par
l'hôpital
j'ai du coup découvert le monde de ce
qu'on appelle la psychiatrie de 7,7
spécialités de la médecine qui s'occupe
des troubles psychiques et mentaux qui
travaillent en équipes qui font un
travail extraordinaire en lien avec
l'hôpital sur les territoires voilà je
rentre pas dans le détail mais
aujourd'hui je suis suivi de très près
par une équipe qui prend soin de moi et
ça ça m'a sam a considérablement aidé
est-ce que tu as souvenir de on est
d'accord regarde pas de pilules magiques
ya pas non plus la phrase magique mais
peut-être un truc un jour qu'ils peuvent
vraiment fait tilter qui potentiellement
peut aider les gens qui vivaient dans
cette vidéo un conseil ou une phrase
well et la phrase la phrase la phrase
que j'avais besoin d'entendre et que
l'on ne plus manger lui dans le livre
c'est tu as le droit d'être malade est
un droit d'être aidé il a fallu qu'à un
moment je m'entende
et donc ça m'a beaucoup aidé et par
ailleurs la dépression est une maladie
qui dans mon cas ne l'est pas mais qui
peut être grave notamment puisque la
dépression est très présente dans les
cartes de suicide et c'est extrêmement
important que les personnes qui
souffrent qui se sentent pas bien qui
peut être dans cette vidéo et en
écoutant se reconnaissent un peu dans ce
que je dis n'hésite pas à plaider des
numéros de téléphone qui sont faits pour
ça se présenter dans des services
d'urgence
la dépression peut avoir différentes
intensités de modérée à grave mais peut
surtout évolué si elle n'est pas prise
en charge selon l'om est chaque année
huit cent mille personnes meurent en se
suicidant
je sais que ça fait peur je me suis
retrouvé moi même aux urgences
psychiatriques de l'hôpital
ça fait peur dit comme ça mais en fait
j'étais au bon endroit et on s'est
occupé de moi et c'est normal c'était ma
place ici c'était la bonne idée donc se
faire idée c'est normal il faut le faire
et c'est quand on en ressent le besoin
il faut il faut pas hésiter vraiment
c'est important ce serait ton conseil
ouais si tu devais adressé directement
aux gens pour le coup de minuit le
règlement pour servir si ça va pas bien
et que vous vous sentez pas bien
n'hésitez pas à
à en parler à votre médecin y compris
votre médecin généraliste c'est son
boulot aussi de vous orienter d'aller
vous faire rencontrer des personnes dont
c'est le boulot
donc voilà vous avez le droit de vous
sentir bien c'est normal ça fait partie
des choses mais vous avez aussi le droit
d'être aidé et je remercie beaucoup
merci à toi julien bonbonnes suite ouest
du chemin pourquoi bah ouais carrément
merci à saluer
[Applaudissements]